Susy is with us in Las Vegas
hi Susy how are you how many good
morning you are you better than I
deserve
how can I help well I have a quick
question my husband and I have saved up
thirty thousand dollars let me know we
want to purchase a car with more lip
yeah we're looking at a Ford f-150 with
that 3.5 6 liter EcoBoost I don't know -
my husband's thing if it gets me from
point A to point B it's good but if it
gets him hunting it's even better so
what the question I have is we have that
set aside we are going to start actually
going and trying to negotiate and I'm
kind of confused I've looked up
different suggestions online and one
site says don't go on a weekend go on a
weekday another one will say don't tell
them you're paying cash we negotiate the
price first because a lot of times the
dealerships feel like they're going to
make money on the back end if they think
you're going to finance I just want to
go and get honest price and a good deal
and leave so I don't know what is what's
the best deal to get to stretch my
dollar the most um what if you're
looking for I'm sorry what is your all's
household income about a hundred
thousand good and what is your net worth
and you're talking about buying a new
truck no no no one you're at or two year
old we're looking for the certified
pre-owned okay yeah well the thing to do
then is um pull the data on the truck
before you go in we need to know what
the truck is worth um we've done that
it's about thirty thousand would be a
good deal well but on individual truck
might be different because you're
looking at a particular truck with miles
on it you're looking at a particular
truck with slightly different equipment
on it and that kind of a thing and so
you know in that you're in the range for
sure on that truck and it is a nice
truck
so you but you pull up you find a
particular one at a dealership sitting
there certified use right and you look
at the exact miles the exact equipment
you enter that in the Kelley Blue Book
calm and maybe look at a couple of the
other sites maybe the Edmonds car guide
and and start to get an idea okay this
car has a retail on it of this and you'd
never pay retail period okay I don't pay
retail period for a car under no
circumstances and you know and so let's
say Kelley Blue Book on the thing
private sale is kind of middle ground
and wholesale is what they pay for the
truck that's what the dealer would pay
for the truck alright and so you want to
be somewhere between private sale and
wholesale at the most and so you go in
knowing let's say private sale is twenty
nine on the truck and wholesales twenty
seven on the truck then you need to be
somewhere north of twenty seven in your
mind and you know maybe they got thirty
one on it I don't know what they got on
it but we walk in there we go look guys
this is cash this is what I would do
this is cash I'm going to write you a
check and I'm going to drive the truck
away and I'm really not gonna stand here
all day and dance with you so if you if
you want to do this I'm willing to write
you a check right now this is a done
deal right it's over but the deed but
the price is twenty seventy five and
just start talking to them that way
and I the back the back end on a used
car is not as big as it is on new car
for them if they sell if they finance it
and sell the paper they make some spread
on it on a new car they make more on it
than they do on the car that's selling
the paper for payments so that sites
advice would be more applicable to a new
car to not tell them you're paying cash
I don't worry about that buying a used
car this is what the truck is worth and
boom I bought a raptor used which is a
similar similar truck Louis yeah I like
those a little more expensive but a
similar truck at nineteen thousand miles
on it was sitting on a local dealers lot
I had bought cars from that dealer
before
and he knows me and i walked in i said
look blue book is on at this you got too
much on this truck and it's not even it
wasn't even a ford lot that it was
sitting on and i said look he want the
thing off a lot I'll take it off a lot
today and that's how we started and I
got a I got a good price on I didn't
steal the truck I didn't steal it but I
got a good price on it um especially
compared to a brand-new one because how
much that thing went down the first year
because there's only a year old when I
bought it
so I'm but anyway you just you just look
at it that way now if you want to steal
a car I mean you might get some
thousands and thousands of dollars under
you're probably looking at buying from
an individual or working with some kind
of a car broker and buying it off the
line where they're running down the
wholesale line what's already let me ask
you when we're kind of afraid that's why
we like the certified cars because
they've already I'm not worried about
that
if it's a question if it's alright if
it's a Ford and it's and it's one year
old you know to worry about that car
it's fine I mean it's just not going to
be a piece of junk the other thing is is
that my husband's kind of afraid to
because we were looking through like
Carfax and everything was when we're
looking online at different cars and he
was saying that rental cars rental cars
that are about a year old rental or
leased cars a lot of them are those and
he's kind of afraid about a leased car
at least a rental car would be something
that would be tough I don't want a car
that's been on rental unless you're
looking for something different but you
know that's that that car has been
ranked out possibly but a leased car is
just an individual owned it and they
tried they had it on one-year lease and
they turned it in it's like that seemed
like anybody else was driving it so just
because it had been leased it doesn't
scare me
but I wouldn't want to buy one that was
a rental as a personal driver now I
might buy for for something in a fleet
or you know if I was doing construction
work or something running a farm truck
or something but this is going to be a
nice driver a nice personal driver
so a lease wouldn't be bad yeah pull the
CARFAX on it that's fine that's fine
one one more question
um when it comes to purchasing the like
a vehicle what are some key phrases or
if I go on to Kelly Blue Book and I just
go on a Kelly Blue Book calm and you and
it all just all pop up yeah you just
click on but click on private sale on
that and then run the numbers on that
particular vehicle and you begin to get
a range on the vehicles you look at and
don't just don't get married to the
first one you roll up on oh I love that
color
oh you're screwed you're going to pay
too much you know because as soon as you
decide you're married to that car you're
getting me to pay too much for it it's
just a car it really is time of the year
or a certain time of the month kind of
the week I wouldn't worry about it the
the thing is that the question is how
long they've had it on the lot most most
used car dealers will keep a car on a
lot only so long and then they'll roll
it through the they'll run it through
the auction and wholesaling get off
their lot they'll turn their money over
and so the I bought a Chevy
four-wheel-drive that we've still got
here at the office we still use it as a
delivery truck about it many many years
ago
and I bought it from that guy and I said
how long you had that thing on the lot
and he said 90 days I said you're
getting ready to roll it off a whole
sale anyway so sell it to me so if
they're if they've been sitting on the
truck a while now if it's a certified
that might not be the case but if
they've been sitting on the truck a
while they may be getting ready to roll
it out because they're not going to keep
it on there six months you're going to
see the same car sitting on the average
dealer is lot six months they're going
to roll it and turn their money because
that units not that units not moving for
them you follow me yes yes thank you and
one more question if you if we choose to
kind of look into the whole sale aspect
of it how do we even do that I've never
done anything like that before
you have to find out what's called a car
broker that and there are people out
there that will go to the auction for
you and you need to be careful that you
find one that is that that's got a good
reputation that you can get that you can
check out so make sure you really do
your your your due diligence and learn
about the person you're working with on
that and the service that they're
providing and have very very clear
expectations on that you're buying a
little bit blind there and that you
might not
see the car you may see pictures of it
learn all the details of it and then it
runs down the line and you're
authorizing them to bid so much on that
car when it goes down the line and
they're you know they may be in a
different city miles and miles away and
then they'll ship it in I've bought two
or three that way over the years you're
probably buying this truck off a lot
somewhere the thing you just don't want
to do is just don't pay too much I doubt
you're going to get it thousands and
thousands of dollars under though but
but you know you just don't want to pay
too much you want to get get you do your
research and know that you've gotten a
hold of something that's strong don't
buy extended warranties either by the
way this is the Dave Ramsey show hey you
guys Rachael Cruz here hope you are
enjoying the Dave Ramsey show and did
you know that I have my very own YouTube
channel yes that's right kind of better
than the Dave Ramsey channel don't tell
them I said that I'm kidding I'm kidding
so subscribe and there's lots of videos
about life and money so while you're at
it if you want to check out a video then
you can check out how to do a monthly
budget it's one of the best videos out
there
you